This conversation, most
conversations, it's an,
it's not you making a statement and
me just reacting to that. Like the,
our conversation of all is based on what
we say, we can interrupt one another,
we can, you know, we can
completely change the subject.
I can take control of the conversation
and the people who might find that
interesting follow it and the folks
that don't just stop listening,
whereas you can't do that in
a post comment model. Yeah.
It's also text is so
limited there. It's, I mean,
it's great for just
getting out actual facts,
but it's also thinking it's just so
close to thinking like if there's no
composition, you know, and, and that's uh,
that to me is the most beautiful thing
about Twitter, but also something that,
you know, can be uncomfortable. Like
I, I can compose my life on Instagram.
I can compose my thoughts within a
Facebook post and it can look so perfect,
but the best of Twitter is
just super raw and it's right.
It's right to the thinking process.
And I just think that's so
beautiful because it gets to,
it gets to consciousness. It gets to
something deeper and I think that defect,
how so? How is it different than a
post on Instagram or post on Facebook?
The speed demands, you know, the, the,
the character constraint, the speed
kind of just demands that, um,
a more conscious,
present focused thinking
versus like stepping back
and kind of closing a letter.
Yeah. In composing a letter and
thinking about all the outcomes.
But oftentimes people do compose it
as a letter and they break it up into
separate 280 character posts.
The other threads.
What was the thought process and
going from one 40 to 80, because I,
the one thing that I liked about one
40 is that you can't be verbose. Yeah.
You can't just,
just ramble and you know,
like it's great for comics because it
forces us to write jokes like with economy
of words. Exactly. We, uh, we
found a lot of resonance with,
with journalists because the headlines,
we found a lot of resonance with a,
with comics because of the rhythm.
And we found a lot of resonance with
hip hop as well because of the bars and
just the structure. And the
constraint allowed that that flow. Um,
the, the thinking was we
looked at, um, our, you know,
languages around the world and,
and uh,
there's some languages like German, 140
characters. You can't really say much.
I can't really say much at all. The words
are so long. There are some languages,
like Japanese 140 characters is 140 words.
And what was interesting about Japan
was Japan is one of our largest,
our largest countries were,
were bigger than Facebook.
There were a lot bigger than Facebook
and America and know what the fuck.
I don't even use Facebook. Sorry.
Facebook. I don't either. I mean,
I use it in terms of a, if I
post something on Instagram,
it goes to Facebook.
But when I go to Facebook,
it's, it just seems like
a lot of both this dizzy like
Twitter to a lot of arguing.
But what is Twitter seems to be more fun,
if that makes any sense.
Even though it's,
there's a lot of chaos when something,
one of my favorite things when someone
post something stupid and then underneath
it is a bunch of jifs. We say gifs or
Jifs. I say Gif. Does anybody know?
Yes it is.
I guess the jury's out a bunch
of gifts that are hilarious.
Like I was just mocking
someone relentlessly.
Like though that is one of my favorite
things about Twitter. I wouldn't.
Someone like Donald Trump posts something
ridiculous and then I'll go and I'll
look at the responses. Right, right.
How don't care. It's a
public conversation. Yeah.
You can see how everyone interacts,
but like it's all,
the interesting thing about Twitter
is there's, there's not one Twitter.
It's like you have politics,
Twitter, which can be super toxic.
You have sports, Twitter, you have
NBA, Twitter, you have MMA, Twitter,
you have a UFC, Twitter, you have k
pop, Twitter, you have a black sports.
What are you up? Black Twitter.
That's Jamie's you. He loves black.
To have all these different
twitters and you and you have a,
you have a completely different
experience based on what Twitter are you
following. What do you
participate in? Some of them
were, are like super engaging,
super funny. Some of them are, um,
do you want to walk away from it?